voilà la lettre adressée par le préfet
jean jacques brot au maire des yvelines
une demande de recensement des offres
d'hébergement
chaque commune a reçu ce tableau qui
devrait être envoyée à la préfecture
objectif centraliser les propositions
d'accueil de famille ukrainienne fuyant
leur pays nous allons créer une
centralisation quelque sorte pour ses
offres
d'hébergement de sorte qu'elle soit bien
connu identifié on les fera remonter au
niveau national et dès qu'il y aura des
arrivées on fera des appariements entre
le type de logement sa situation sera
pas que sa proximité avec un moyen de
transport etc et les besoins des
familles au cas par cas dans la mesure
du possible je recommande que ces
propositions de logement d'hébergement
soit accompagnée de propositions
d'accompagnement c'est très important
que on n'ajoute pas au déracinement à
l'exil à la crainte de la guerre et de
ses conséquences en plus une situation
d'isolement dans les yvelines en france
officiellement il n'ya pas encore
d'arriver dans les yvelines mais des
ukrainiens déjà présent en france au
moment du déclenchement de la guerre
sont accueillis au campus des mureaux
huit jeunes au total âgés de 16 à 39 ans
nous assurons à ce jeune le gîte et le
couvert il va falloir aussi une aide
d'urgence pour qu'il puisse habiller son
parti pour quelques jours donc avec
quelques vêtements il va falloir aussi
leur trouver une activité
des activités rémunératrices parce
qu'ils n'ont rien
des activités taux courts de la
formation en particulier la formation
linguistique il faut qu'ils apprennent
le français par ailleurs des commune
yvelinoise se mobilisent déjà en
proposant des collectes vêtements
produits d'hygiène ou encore literie des
points de dons sont mises en place
notamment à poissy aux mureaux ou encore
à carrières sous poissy